all right let's go back to discord uh
davidpakman.com
discord we're hearing from people in the
audience the most important people let's
go to keir
from scotland kier you're on the air
hi david um i just uh just wondered if
you had any thoughts i don't know if
you're aware of what's happened in the
uk today but um our prime minister for
the last months
started out denying that he'd had any
parties in number 10 downing street then
he said he didn't know that it was a
party
um and then and then he said oh yes it
was a party but i wasn't aware and now
today he's been handed out um him his
wife and the chancellor of exchequer
have all been handed out 50 pound fines
yeah for breaching walk down those rules
that they wrote
um and they are all um and there's over
50 now people who live in downing street
that have all been handed out these
fines
and it there's it's he's got over a 75
uh dislike with the public today in
polls today
um i was just wondering if you had any
comment on it or if if you thought
because he's refusing to resign as is
his
chancellor yeah
listen
on the resignation i i can't comment on
the resignation piece you know it's
really for those it's i want to leave
that to voters and others in the uk to
comment on but if there's anything good
about this now we can look at it and say
a 50-pound fine is pathetically low and
you you're you know sure that's true but
i think it's good that at least they're
being held to the standards where in
some places it would just be excused if
that's the punishment that should be
assigned i'm glad that it's being
assigned if the rules were broken also
like how much of this has to do with the
what is the definition of a party in the
uk
this is the thing is that he wrote the
rules right the people wrote the rules
about what our party was but he doesn't
seem to know himself what a party is
which is absolutely insane to me um i'm
just well i've got you here as well um
do you think this is going to push uh
perhaps towards scotland getting another
one another independence
this specifically boris johnson's party
you mean
just the litany of things that he's done
over the last few years of just lying in
parliament and illegally pro parliament
he lied to the queen he's just i could
let the list of things i could say he's
just i'm just wondering like this is
this going to be
is this going to be the final thing
where the people of scotland are just
going to say enough is enough we're done
with you i don't know what will be the
proverbial uh straw that breaks the
camel's back but my sense for several
years in reading about scotland has been
that
there's at least some clamoring for
another independence vote i mean you you
tell me is that the sense you get
i think so yes i think there's a lot of
people who previously
um either didn't vote or wanted to stay
in the union because of again lies told
in the thing yeah calling the referendum
on the run up to the referendum who have
now just just had enough they don't they
want the fed up with the constant lies
and
just just the constant nonsense coming
out of westminster you just want done i
i do wonder i'm so i'm totally sensitive
to that and you know it's
it's the people of scotland that need to
decide i'm not taking a position one way
or the other i'm wondering if you
like are you aware and does it concern
you that there may be economic
difficulties in scottish independence is
that a discussion
no that's that's not really it's not
really a problem there's a lot of sort
of people who are like oh you you take
more from england you don't it's more
it's more complex than that because we
have a lot of offshore oil and there's a
lot of other ways like we can make a lot
of money out of tourism uh the real
problem is is um
we can't have a referendum
a legally binding referendum unless
westminster says we're allowed to right
boris johnson has outright stated he
will not allow that to happen sure so
even even if the
msps decide that they're going to have a
referendum he can just ignore it and say
no you're not getting independence i
don't care what the referendum you had
says right right right right that is a
difficult situation
yeah yeah very difficult it doesn't
really feel like self-determination in
that sense
um yeah it's a it's a bit of a sticky
situation i don't know how you get out
of it yeah
well
i really appreciate your call and uh for
you filling us in on what's going on
there
oh thank you for your time sir all right
there is keir from scotland a beautiful
phone call for sure
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
fifteen percent off all products and
free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below